we turned to Bob Cusack editor-in-chief
of the hill Bob good morning good
morning
we looked close to a deal with China not
like a week ago what happened I was a
lot more optimistic they wouldn't get a
deal because there was motivation on
both sides China's economy is not doing
strong Trump needs economy strong what
about a week ago China started walking
away from key facets of the deal
including including on currency
manipulation and that really I talked to
some people the White House that really
rattled them you know one of the big
groups that's been affected by this or
will be certainly is agriculture what
does that mean for farmers that reaction
but also the Senators the Republican
senators from a lot of those states
Republican senators from farm States are
very nervous and they have been lobbying
the White House to either get a deal or
just continue the talks and we this
can't continue into 2020 this is what
they said but Trump's not listening
Trump is just senator Grassley I said
listen you've had enough time we need to
make progress and Trump has put the
tariffs on and it's really frustrating a
lot of farmers certainly is let's turn
now to the fallout the continued fallout
over the Russia investigation the
president basically said I'm exerting
executive privilege here on the full
muddled report what kind of impact is
that going to have and you know just
this testimony that we're talking about
that Muller might bring to Congress
about how crucial is that at this stage
I think that's crucial I think he
potentially can block down the gain from
testifying his former counsel I don't
think he can block Muller though and
remember Bill Barr said he has no
problem with Muller testifying
I think Muller's testimony is so key and
I think that could be the decider of
whether House Democrats move forward on
a Pietschmann whether he contradicts
anything that Muller the bar told
congressman so what I mean what happens
if Muller does get to Congress and he
basically says bars interpretation is
incorrect
then I think it's gonna be very
difficult for House Democrats not to
move forward with impeachment or at
least some type of censure I think
that's more likely accenture than
impeachment cuz Nancy Pelosi does not
want to impeach she's spoken out very
strongly against that right now at this
point yes but she's having trouble
controlling the left wing of her party
and more Democrats who were against
impeachment now because of all the
stonewalling
now the for impeachment well what about
Republicans are they holding the line
completely well until until Don junior
was subpoenaed by the republican-led
Senate Intelligence Committee Senator
Bob burr they were very frustrated with
burr and they were like what are you
doing they were united now that the
Senate Intelligence Committee
investigation is a little bit different
than the Muller but still russia-related
it it depends on what burr does now does
he back down now that the President and
and Trump jr. are saying listen I'm not
gonna show up mm-hmm so I mean this
impeachment issue is tricky because as
we've seen in polls generally the public
is not in favor of Congress beginning
impeachment at the same time do you
think to any degree the Republicans
would like the Democrats to go down that
road yes and that's what Nancy pose has
been saying is that a the the president
is basically goading us into impeaching
and she says listen it's very divisive
thing to impeach the president yeah we
know that the Senate would not convict
so I until polling changes I don't think
Nancy Pelosi changes her mind
one of the issues at the end of the week
I don't know if I can sum this up in a
quick sentence but basically we heard
that the president's attorney Rudy
Giuliani is going to Ukraine
investigating Joe Biden and then a
couple days later no he's not going to
Ukraine now what has happened Giuliani
took a lot of heat for that and really
looking into the ties of Biden's son to
Ukraine but they're worried about Joe
Biden Joe Biden's gotten off to a very
good start he's dominating the primary
he's definitely the front-runner and
they're nervous about him in a general
election yeah I mean we saw that with
Trump in the original campaign went
after the ones right away and that
public Messiah he was concerned with
absolute loom boom Bob thank you Bob
Cusack thank you